[Musique]
ce matin dans le quartier de la duchère
à lyon un important dispositif policier
était toujours déployé trois policiers
de la brigade anticriminalité ont essuyé
des tirs alors qu'ils réalisaient une
surveillance classique d'un points de
deal à partir du moment où vous avez
retiré beaucoup de forces de l'ordre du
terrain pendant des années il faut en
remettre mais t il force dublin comme
dit sur le terrain oui mais ce que le
faut le faire réellement il faut
recruter il faut former et une volonté
de tuer il ya une volonté d'agresser il
ya une sauvagerie absolument
insupportable dans notre société on le
voit la duchère mais on l'a vu avec un
professeur qui est décapité en pleine
rue une enquête pour tentative
d'homicide a été ouverte et doit
désormais faire la lumière sur le nombre
exact de tireurs ça fait trois fois que
je lui en parle en un an et demi de
remettre davantage de caméras dans les
endroits où il ya le plus de difficultés
nous appelons les maires de france et
singulièrement motionnaire de lyon de
sortir d'idéologie et d'aider les
policiers et en mettant des caméras puis
de protection dont qu'on a réaffecté
certaines caméras c'est en cours ça
n'était pas encore fait effectivement
hier soir mais c'est en cours l'idée
c'est d'optimiser en permanence notre
couverture beaucoup fait y'a pas de a
pas d'idéologie moi je suis extrêmement
pragmatique la politique est violente
parce que la société est violente parce
que on voit bien que le style
aujourd'hui compris d'un certain nombre
de candidats est celui des réseaux
sociaux ans à eric zemmour je pense pas
qu'à eric zemmour parce que c'est très
collectif et pardon il ya aussi une part
médiatique son postulat est celui la
capacité de notre société à changer
regarder si on peut voir la citation
cela veut-il dire qu'il faudra arrêter
toutes les liaisons aériennes
intérieures dans l'hexagone arrêté
l'habitat début elle est imposée le
télétravail si les français ressentent
que derrière l'idéologie il ya derrière
l'écologie à une idéologie de classe une
idéologie d'une gauche radicale ils
marcheront pas est ce que vous avez
entendu les écolos dire on arrête
l'habitat individuel non mais elle va
nous faire les chars russes les
kolkhozes les sovkhoze et on va tous
habitait dans le même immeuble on va
partager nos appartements et nos salles
de bain sur l'écologie c'est pas une
douche froide par mois dans le noir
pourtant vous y aviez cru très fort si
vous avez présidé une société
d'éoliennes les arbres avant elle a fait
faillite je n'étais pas le créateur ni
le dirigeant mais elle a fait faillite
j'ai perdu un peu d'argent mais
économies parce que ça n'était pas
rentable on va pas faire la campagne sur
le passé on va pas faire la campagne sur
le monde d'avant crise à le manger c est
pour toutes les droites sutil droits
particuliers qui séduit toutes les
droites % des français ajoute les droits
y arrête un mois jour j j'en ai dit
qu'on parle du mandat sous des affiches
z 2022 vous envoyez nous une à gauche
une à droite une zemmour président au
milieu tout est donc parfaitement assumé
dans son discours un également j'ai
longtemps imaginé un candidat qui
pourrait porter nos idées il devient
possible que ce soit moi quand je vois
le soutien que vous m'apportez voilà ce
qu eric zemmour a dit les dernières
infos sur lankais du coup de feu tiré
par alec baldwin sur le tirage sur le
tournage de son dernier film l'assistant
réalisateur qui lui a fourni larmes a
des antécédents il a déjà été licencié
d'un précédent tournage pour un accident
impliquant une arme à feu également une
créature au sens où il y à une douce
tolérance le pouvoir et même une forme
de deal avec les propriétaires les
propriétaires des télévisions dans
lesquels finalement il ya eu une sorte
de d'émergence ça fait combien d'années
que ça dure il ya même des tee-shirts
ont été créées qui reprennent un slogan
célèbre de la nra où on dit c'est
qu'elle ne se sont pas les armes qui
tuent ce sont ceux qui les manipulent
ils ont fait la même chose sont pas les
armes qui tuent mme c'est alec baldwin
que fait le csa faisait remarquer le
saissac et toujours qui a des idées
décompter le temps de parole lui mais
que d'un polémiste qui n'est pas encore
candidat je vois que vous défendez bien
le sésame ce t-shirt est en vente sur le
site officiel de donald trump junior
donald trump junior qui met donc en
vente ses t-shirts et qui aux cibles
délibérément le militant tiers mkii et
alec baldwin